et récession moins forte que prévue en
2020 pourtant malgré ces mauvaises
nouvelles perspectives de rebond révisé
à la hausse par le fmi le ciel bleu ciel
on dirait pas semble s'éclaircir pour
l'économie française en ce début d'année
2021 à mesure que l'épidémie de kobe tu
se stabilise dans le monde mais derrière
les gros tickets les la réalité de cette
reprise en france comme d'ailleurs dans
le reste de l'europe est elle à la
mesure du redémarrage en trombe qui se
profile aux états unis après le
spectaculaire redressement machine c'est
l'objet de notre édito échos ce soir
bonsoir j'accepte ya merci d'être avec
nous bonsoir c'est fanny alors récession
moins forte que prévu le choc de
l'épidémie aurait donc été moins grave
que ce qui avait été annoncé jacques oui
tout à fait les derniers chiffres
donnent une récession ou une dépression
2 - vie de 8 3%
c'est effectivement nettement moins que
ce que les économistes estiment et
jusqu'à maintenant
bruno le maire a parlé de -10% moi même
j'avais avancé des chiffres qui allait
jusqu'à -1 11%
donc oui d'une certaine manière les
chiffres sont beaucoup moins mauvais que
ce qui était prévu
maintenant il faut tout de suite dire
que une dépression de -8 3% dans une
année c'est quelque chose absolument
sans précédent en france ce sont des
chiffres qui sont de l'ordre de ceux de
la crise de 1929 donc néanmoins le choc
économique sur la france a été un choc
majeur est par ailleurs il faut aussi
dire que les l'ensemble du contexte
économique qui entoure ces chiffres est
très loin d'être rassurant alors avant
d'aller plus loin dans l'analyse jacques
peut-on dire sur les chiffres de 2020
alors sur 2020 si vous voulez l'ensemble
de l'économie monde
elle a connu une dépression très nette
une dépression qui est en moyenne de - 3
et demi pour cent donc on voit bien là
que la france se situe 13 ans de ça en
réalité de la dépression mondiale
alors ce qu'on peut remarquer ces deux
choses premièrement le fait qu' il y a
deux zones qui ont été particulièrement
frappé la zone euro moins 7,2 pour cent
et l'amérique latine - 7,4 pour cent
ce sont des chocs qui sont extrêmement
avancé quant au contraire les économies
émergentes d'asie n'ont connu une
récession que deux mois 1,1 pour cent
donc ça c'est déjà un premier problème
et puis la deuxième chose qu'il faut
dire que c'est que à l'évidence les
économies avancées des économies de
vieilles industrialisation en fait
eh bien ce sont les économies qui ont
connu des récessions qui sont très
largement supérieur à la moyenne
mondiale des récessions de l'ordre de -
5 % alors que la moyenne mondiale est à
-3 et demi pour ça alors on n'est que de
savoir ce qui s'est passé dans ces pays
pour quelle raison justement que s'est
il passé
c'est là où il y a eu des choses très
intéressant parce que dans ces pays de
vieille industrialisation on voit qu'il
y a des différences assez importantes
entre pays par exemple d'abord il ya les
états unis alors les états unis ils ont
d'abord ils ont moins souffert de la
crise due qu'à vide que les autres pays
et surtout aujourd'hui ils connaissent
1re démarrage en fanfare de l'économie
qu'il s'agisse du redémarrage de la
consommation bien entendu une
consommation qui a été boostée par
l'échec qui ont été données à tous les
ménages américains mais aussi la très
bonne résistance des économies du
numérique et écrans géants du numérique
les gaffes acquis sont américains et
enfin quelques dont on parle assez que
c'est le rebond de l'industrie
pétrolière après si on regarde justement
en europe on voit qu'il y a
deux phénomènes qui sont très nets
premier phénomène c'est que un pays
comme l'allemagne et auquel on peut
associer le japon qui est un pays
asiatique mais dont la structure
économique et industriel est assez
proche de la dinde cpi ne résiste pas
mal du tout puisqu'ils sont autour de -
5 - 5 et 10% par rapport à ces pays la
france qu'on associés d'ailleurs plutôt
à ce type de pays eh bien elle se
retrouve très décalé et elle se retrouve
elle plutôt au niveau de pays comme
l'italie l'espagne voire le royaume uni
qui conte connu des des pressions
extrêmement fortes
avec la crise sanitaire donc il ya aussi
une chose qui apparaît c'est aujourd'hui
une forme de divergences au sein des
pays industrialisés au sein et en
particulier des pays européens
on voit une divergence qui est en train
de s'ouvrir entre eux l'europe du nord
et l'europe du sud et la question cette
situation va-t-elle perdurer avec la
reprise
alors là tu stéphanie vous avez tout à
fait raison parce que là ce sont les
chiffres sur 2020 donc il faut peut être
regarder aujourd'hui ce qui va se passer
sur l'avenir est là quand on regarde les
prévisions qui sont faites par le fonds
monétaire international
ce sont des chiffres qui ont été publiés
à la fin du mois de janvier mais qu'est
ce qu'on voit on voit que les économies
européennes allemagne france espagne
italie sont plutôt au bas du graphique
elles ne retrouveront leurs niveaux de
2018 qu'en 2029 pour l'allemagne la
france et l'espagne
probablement 2023 seulement pour
l'italie alors que au contraire et bien
la chine et les économies émergentes
d'asie
elle caracole en tête ce qui fait peser
le risque d'une forme de déclassement de
l'europe par rapport aux pays david
alors quand on est vous jacques par un
déclassement de l'europe
justement si vous voulez le fait que
l'europe et les états unis aussi
représentés dans les années 1950 1960 le
coeur
l'industrie le coeur de la croissance en
fait au niveau mondial et qu'est ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui eh bien on voit
que l'union européenne qui en 2002
faisait à peu près 20% du pig mondiale
bon alors en parité de pouvoir d'achat
eh bien il est tombé à 16 % en 2013 2014
et il tombera
si on en croit le fonds monétaire
international à 12% en 2022 par rapport
à ça
ce que l'on constate aussi c'est
l'explosion
littéralement des pays d'asie émergente
qui était à 17 % c'est-à-dire chou la
part de l'union européenne en 2002 qui
ont atteint grosso modo 30 % en 2013
2014 et qui depuis 2019
et là encore si on croit les prévisions
du fmi vont continuer à avancer très
fortement puisqu'il devrait atteindre en
2022 à peu près 42 % du pib mondial
donc le déclassement c'est ça c'est le
fait que alors que l'union européenne et
les pays d'asie émergente faisait à peu
près jeu égal l'union européenne était
même au dessus des pays de l'asie
émergente en 2002 en 2022 donc vingt ans
après et bien l'union européenne ne
représentera plus que 30% de la part du
pib des pays d'asie émergente
c'est cela le déclassement alors jacques
peut-on espérer que le plan de relance
européen permettra justement d'inverser
cette tendance
si vous voulez là encore
il y à ce qui est dit et puis il ya la
réalité un ce plan il a il faut le
rappeler il a été adopté à l'été dernier
donc à l'été 2020 il ne sera en réalité
mis en oeuvre qu'à l'été 2021 au mieux
je dis bien au mieux peut-être même ce
sera plutôt vers la fin de demie de
l'inter et alors qu'est ce qu'il prévoit
il prévoit grosso modo 750 milliards
d'euros sur deux ans je dis bien sûr
deux ans alors que si on regarde les
sommes qui ont été dépensées en 2020
donc sur une année les sommes
budgétaires qui ont été dépensés en 2020
pour sept pays
eh bien on voit que c'est ces pays de
l'union européenne et sept pays
d'ailleurs de la zone euro eh bien ils
ont à eux c'est déjà dépensé plus de 760
milliards d'euros donc qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que un le plan
européen est très en-deça des besoins de
l'union européenne et de la zone euro
ces besoins ils ont d'ailleurs été
estimé par le parlement européen
autour de 2000 milliards dont on voit qu
on en est très loin
deuxièmement à travers toute une série
d'astuces comptable sur les 750
milliards on sait très bien qu'il n'y
aura que 500 milliards d'argent frais et
donc qu'est ce qu'on se disait on se dit
que de ce point de vue là le plan de
l'union européenne
il est très présente deux sens de ce
qu'il faudrait faire
si nous voulions réellement rattraper ou
moins stabilisé notre situation par
rapport aux pays d'asie
alors on se demande jacques où sont les
bonnes nouvelles alors y'a quand même
des bonnes nouvelles il faut lire les
bonnes nouvelles
elles portent plutôt sur le passé oui
c'est vrai la crise 2020 a été moins
grave que ce que l'on pouvait craindre
et je répète avec moins vite moins 8,3
pour cent vingt-six c'est un chiffre
assez terrible en lui mais al malgré
tout c'est mieux que ce que l'on pouvait
craindre encore
au mois de novembre au mois de décembre
c'est à dire des chiffres de moins 10
mois 11 voire -12%
donc oui il y a une bonne nouvelle en ce
qui concerne le choc de 2020 mais quand
on regarde ce qui va se passer en 2021
et en 2022 en particulier avec la fin
progressive des aides qui vont d'une
certaine manière révéler les dégâts qui
ont été faits dans l'économie bien quand
on se tourne vers le futur eh bien on
voit là que la situation est extrêmement
préoccupante que l'union européenne est
en train de décrocher dans la
compétition mondiale rapport aux pays de
l'asie émergente et que nous en france
nous sommes en particulier tirée vers le
bas par cette situation de l'union
européenne alors que l'allemagne
s'il faut parler d'elle justement eh
bien elle est d'ores et déjà prête à ne
pas respecter toute une série de règles
de l'union européenne
elle est prête déjà à lancer ses propres
plans sans trop se soucier de ce qui
sera fait en europe et donc on peut
quand même un moment donné se poser la
question est ce qu'il ne serait pas tant
que la france élabore une politique
économique réellement nationale si elle
veut survivre dans les prochaines années
merci jacques beaucoup de questions
merci pour cet éclairage édifiant à tout
point de vue est la semaine prochaine